this is on the glass closet I thought to
be perfect talk to these guys
about it if you don't know the term the
glass closet
it is I'm gonna read this because I want
to get it fully right it is a term used
for a gay person usually a public figure
or celebrity
who has never publicly come out as being
gay but he's basically known
to be gay there are many of these people
now I'm not gonna out anyone
we had a debate before the show I'm not
going to out anyone here
but I have written four names here on
this piece of paper
I don't want you guys to repeat these
names but there are four teams here
that are very very public people I in
Hollywood wanna major TV star
won a major movie star won a major music
music star
it cetera that pre which everyone in the
gay community knows he's gay
again I am NOT outing any when I just
want you guys to look at this with keep
an eye on me for a second so that the
white shutters and even see this
okay now we're just looking at that one
ovens begin news and sort it has been
how did recently by a major newspaper
okay now my question is this: yes
with these people I have no reason to
think that any of them are anti-gay
actually some Obama done publicly
pro-gay things
but yet they still refuse to just say
and I'm curious as
out people you guys put a lot of stuff
out there you put your false else out
there
you put a lot of skin out there I got
but I i a
yeah literally your but your skin in the
game via I M Google held
skin into his K whatever whatever works
yeah really how I i cuz I feel very
conflicted by these people I have no
doubt that they're all good people
and private we doing good things and
probably living happy lives in all at
but
as out people how should we feel about
this group of people that sorta
tacitly endorsing this idea that you can
live your life
still but don't say either wanna view
take it away I would say that the coming
out process
is different for everyone and that
there's no
right way to do it there's no time that
you need to do a by and
and not the number letting any of them
off the hook but
that there probably at potentially a
different point to the coming out
journey into I think it's very
hard to be critical love people and
and in where they're at and we see the
same thing with
with you keepers like that their
youtubers that are in the closet
and it's easy for us as oughtn't versus
a what were you doing
way come out you can do so much for the
cause you help change hearts and minds
but babe just might not be very I i mean
there's a lot
a processing the house the happen to get
to that point right now get I don't know
anymore they're waiting for the book
deal
so that's a big maybe what a whore
because I don't know any these people
personally but
I'm good at the poor people that I wrote
down here I'm pretty sure these are all
millionaires
prolly multimillionaires a n isn't that
that tacit endorsement
that they're sorta saying what I could
lose this you not to lose my TV show I
could lose my movie
it senator isn't that sorted the worst
message you could be sending to
a 15-year-old that maybe wants to go in
the movies
Iranian want to be an actor is in the ER
is mid a subliminal message there that
this is almost like the worst thing you
could possibly do
and I mean if I were to speculate and
I'm
rock not really in a position to do so I
can only speak from my own experience
but one of them is also fairly quite
young
as prominent a figure as he is is yeah I
think people is pretty so I would I
think that it's their own
emotional journey and I have no problem
with them choosing to remain in the
closet
because they are so prominent in the
public eye
as long as you're not living a life of
pot hypocrisy so ready as if you're not
a
you know vocally voting yet voting
against gay rights or sorry expressing
your disdain
we r then we're cool and as far as I
know
most of these people have also been
vocal supporters
%uh gay rights they just never join the
club themselves a bit like the bike oh
yeah
gave a great love gave that not me but
let gay rights ok that's the weird thing
and I think that's why everyone feel so
conflicted when I showed you guys this
list
both sorta backed up like oh shit we
better not talk about that with good
there is
this unsaid thing right that we
shouldn't really
if we were to say this these names
people go berserk right I do you want to
respect people's privacy I know they're
coming out with
a difficult process for myself and I
wasn't even
online when that happened it was just my
own little world I was so unbelievably
afraid so one can imagine just what
they're going to do as I wanna be
responsive
tell that I would like to and once
they're out a
tell me your story girl let's let's
let's hear it what do I do with it I
totally agree cuz that's why did this
event like this and in plastering
under the is the hypocrisy issue is that
the big one for you if you saw these
four names and saw that one of them was
somehow doing some sort I had a gating
with that lead you more
right I i mean that's what what means
bad
well bad taste in your mouth so it's a
so it's only yeah
media me belated yeah I got
I think that's where cross the line in
the message that you were saying I love
like you know they're millionaires and
they're afraid there
that's probably not the message that
they think that they're putting out I
agree I don't think they're proactively
believing that they're doing something
bad but I do think especially
for one of these people who is an actor
who wasn't so hugely successful
there is somehow the implication that my
success is based
and me not coming out and I think that's
really dangerous
and I that doesn't mean I'm gonna out
him or even think I don't even think
poorly of him I don't know him
but I i think that that conflicting
message is still something that the gay
community
is hasn't quite grappled people only
think the message that he's putting our
is is not in your fucking business
and and this is my personal life in its
in it doesn't matter should be it
like the methods that were receiving
isn't the same message that he thinks
he's putting out
a and and a big kind is what it is
yet I don't bother valid to I think his
perspective it is
it is out there are certain things that
as public as I am there something that I
just don't talk about pressure and
you're not going to get me to talk about
the cats love your
condemned it will you at least write
them on this paper rather not take this
I don't talk about my out and buying
rope any relationship collect seen
youtuber celebrities we all thought you
know when you get into very public you
romantic entanglements in the public eye
it just about never very good I know
when you started your blog you to talk
about where and gather your day
yeah separating church and state they
will keep something secret for him his
insect oriented for some these people
sexual orientation
might be sacred space for them I don't
know